[Music]
from a studio celebrating its 100th
birthday with the energy of a real
100-year-old comes another chapter of
the Multiverse Saga that's taken the MCU
from mustat to maybe throw it on in the
background while you're doing something
else it's really
good
[Applause]
Loki Season
2 Season 1 was a delight now prepare for
a followup that laughs at the basics of
Storytelling too complicated wait am I
on the wrong page or spits in the face
of physics it's your future my present
it's complicated but can't shake the law
of diminishing returns it's too
complicated to explain it to you now as
your Marvel fatigue gets pushed to the
rink by a circular argument over what's
even going on this time I don't
understand what you've just said it's
high time someone tells me exactly what
is going on what a waste of time Loki's
back and now he literally can't get his
head out of his own
ass watch this slickback Norman complete
his journey from Bad Boy to a reformed
anti-hero to a cop whose only friends
are his
co-workers as this former trickster
makes like a tree and weaves growing
from the most dynamic villain in MCU
history to a sad green Throne potato a
cheer up Loki did someone forget to take
their vitamins hi
sh you look
great meet Marvel's next big villain he
who won't go away even though the actor
is literally on trial for domestic
violence they're still doubling down on
a guy who just got bodied by Ant-Man
Antman this season follow a Kang variant
named Victor timley won with the power
to end a sentence dramatic pause roud
fine threads of
power or end a sentence dramatic pause
regular
time is the future
of energy he's teamed up with the tva's
top middle manager Ren layer and a big
horny clock what I could have been your
girl in this ridiculous fantasy where
multiple women are attracted to a guy
who's really indis
steampunk bye ooh clock blocked a
technical hiccup at the TVA has put
every timeline in Jeopardy the branching
is overloading the temple Loop now the
only way to fix it is a bunch of
nonsense that would get you laughed out
of a doctor who Rider's room the
containment do are locked and only the
person who designed it can open it with
a Life Scan of his temporal Aura that's
right the whole season is about getting
a door open with seven layers of mumbo
jumbo added on so we can't get there and
increase the diameter of the Looms
intake ring enough to boost throughput
you need to get to the temporal Loom so
the extractor can pull Loki directly out
of the time streak would to allow it to
interface directly with time's adaptive
exponential Computing system with all
those upgrades it would allow the loom
to scale the capacity to manage the
backlog of branches it just keeps going
on like this for six episodes when
something is pruned it's released from
time so the hope is that after you prune
yourself the extractor will pull you
into the present of
course yeah
Loki won't lurk the office Halls alone
his pal Mobius is back with one new
personality trait liking snacks
crackerjack concession stand is a hi
traffic area let's have a little pie
while we wait courtesy of the hot CUO
machine great Donuts today Dale Owen
Wilson makes the best of a role that's
just Owen Wilson doing Owen Wilson stuff
braad I saw the poster it looked scary
wow I'm cheerful with a hint of sadness
behind the nice W Ora boros is here to
give kiwan a much deserved paycheck
proving that it's never too late to be
typ cast as a lovable nerd who does
machines and of course Sylvie returns to
remind the viewer what's really at stake
McDonald's you like it here you like
this place I thought you were setting us
up for an ambush hell you were just
setting us up for a great meal what
would you like I want to try
everything she's looking it to save the
Multiverse watch Loki and his crew
dramatically run
around time is of the essence let's go
faster this
time occasionally pause to find each
other if they're here we'll find them we
need to find Sylvie we find R there we
find Miss minutes but you said you
wanted to find Sylvie right maybe Miss
minutes can locate him where is Sylvie
lus where is he find Sylvie where is she
where's d where Sylvie and how are we
going to find a little rogue cartoon
clock that doesn't want to be found
forget who they are I don't know you you
don't know me have we met each other I
think you have me mixed up with someone
else that guy that was here what was his
name this isn't the first time we've had
this conversation is it Casey it's me
who are you you don't remember me either
you were in just the other day
right and repeat until creatively
exhausted I want to introduce you
to in a season of TV that gives up and
restarts like a speedrunner trying to
100% dark souls this all seems a bit
rushed welcome to the MCU post end game
so gather around for a show that can
only be understood as a grand metaphor
for the current state of Marvel itself
they've expanded into TV too much too
fast it's not constructed to weave
together so many new branches so it's
overloading it looks like a disaster it
is a disaster risk the sacred timeline
where they stuck to making movies hey
what were you doing down there on the
sacred timeline making movies as they
all avoid the simple answer staring them
right in the face you can't scale with
infinite unplug the whole thing wait a
beat then plug it back in again once we
forgotten how much this face sucked I
can rewrite the story
please
staring Loki in the sky with timelines
lighning mxtreme two all beef patty
Special Sauce lettuce cheese pickles
onions on a branch timeline Vic Mena
respect my time ber Ador in another life
I would have really liked doing tech
support with you Tik Tock influencer I
am the very model of a modern major
Disney role tech support support Raphael
is cool but rude Liza erands and the
mcu's visual effects are artist the work
is really pile up if I take a break so I
just keep add it forever no sleep hot
tom time
machine not to self before commissioning
a propaganda Mosaic of the tva's origins
don't commission a bronze relief of the
horrible horrible truth hey screen
junkies let's keep slipping through time
in an all new episode of BU the numbers
where we used more science Mumbo jum
than Loki to objectively pick the
all-time greatest year for movies click
the Box on the right to watch
now I am epic voice guy of Memphis and I
am burdened with glorious purpose you
shall not pass I serve a higher
authority Pingu
Pingu